warum hat er ausgerechnet bei einer rtl
reportage mitgemacht das erklärte jetzt
in fragen laut ob und wann bei ihm die
pulswerte in die höhe von profisportlern
erklettern das und viel mehr jetzt
infrage mit juli also jetzt geht es hart
auf hart
das sind wer weiß es so da sind gemeinde
und harmlose fragen die grünen sind
harmlos die roten sind gemein du kannst
selber wählen du kannst entscheiden
wieviel frage du möchtest und welche
farbe du wählst bitteschön stadt erstmal
mit einer grün würde ich sagen ich habe
ich mal weiter bis empfindlich scheint
mehr
das ist genau
okay obwohl du oft unterschätztes
gewinnst du häufig das erfolgsgeheimnis
das haben wir vorher schon oder kurz
angesprochen ich würde sagen dass vor
allem ein bisschen making und das halt
auch in stressigen situationen kühlen
kopf bewahren kann
okay da will ich sagen jetzt eine rote
wenn du in stressigen situationen kühlen
kopf bewahren ganz okay
musste das sein dass du ausgerechnet bei
rtl einen beitrag über gamer mit macht
ja die hatten ja im vorfeld oder
ungefähr ein halbes jahr feier ziemlich
viel stress bekommen wegen dem gamescom
bericht vom letzten jahr und im prinzip
weiter aus sondern ich würde sagen eine
art entschuldigung an die gamer weil der
beitrag um ich war dann doch deutlich
positiv und dann denke ich oder dachte
ich das war halt eine gute chance um die
gamer ist im ganz schlechten auf der
rechten ecke wieder rauszuholen und
verhallt im vorfeld schon abgesprochen
dass das klar wird dass wir dann keinen
mist machen und das versprechen haben
sie gehalten
das haben sie auch gehalten ok also sie
sich die roten fragen sind so schlimm
ich wenn man was darauf zu antworten
weiß dann nehme ich mal noch eine rote
wer das nicht besser was vernünftiges
leben zu machen als den ganzen tag vor
dem pc zocken
also wenn ich irgendwie ich habe vor
allem gefangen informatik zu studieren
da wäre ich auch den ganzen tag vorm pc
also das argument ist halt nicht so gut
und man kommt auch viel rum also ich bin
jetzt hier ich bin noch viel an events
eigentlich ist das immer noch ein gutes
mittel um mal von zu hause weg zu kommen
von öl auf europa wechsel kommen das ist
ja ein irrtum
wer online ist ist ja nicht offline
quasi der ist ja der ist ja im echten
leben nicht offline sondern es kommt ja
immer was das ist ja eine riesen
community zum beispiel die esl mit allem
pipapo sport ist inzwischen unglaublich
populär geworden
ich schaffte es in diesem zirkus ort zu
bleiben ich muss sagen mir gar keine
gedanken drüber gemacht also es hat
nicht so dass im kino verstellt oder
irgendwie was macht was ich nicht machen
will sondern ich genieße das allein fach
und bleibt doch so wie ich bin und man
muss darauf hin was vorspielen damit
weiter mitmachen zu können
tiefenentspannt wasser der seite schon
immer ich denke schon ja
also es gibt ja viele leute auch die in
einer schule dann prüfungsangst haben
oder so das hatte ich zum beispiel nie
bei mir was sie einmal so ein bisschen
anders rum dass mir irgendwie in
kavernen sachen eingefallen sind und ich
gar nicht mehr wusste darf kino weiß
besser geworden ist das ergebnis all
gestartet
jetzt mal ehrlich es heißt für isport
aber besonders fit muss man dafür nicht
sein oder
ja erst einmal keinen körperlich
anstrengender sport aber trotzdem wenn
man in wien wichtiges lange spiel hatte
ganz nationen am ende erschöpft und
ausgelaugt also mental strebt das schon
da man muss halt die ganze zeit hoch
konzentriert sein
ich war als letztes jahr auf der
dreamhack hatten die spieler von final
an so herz monitore angeschlossen und da
die pulse die ärzte zu messen
dagegen hat auch schon richtig hoch im
profisport bereiche die man ansonsten
nur auf fußball fluss kennt also deshalb
bei missbrauch nicht nur so dass der da
nur mit der maus so ein bisschen rum
datteln man das halt so ein bisschen
aber du hast ja die geringere action
zahl pro minute
ja genau so lässt es dann doch ruhig
angehen ja auch beim spielen ein
bisschen ruhe gaben auch immer geschafft
letzte grüne fragen auf er macht ja auch
noch
diese kommt ein großteil so gut bei den
fans an ich glaube an gott ist halt das
feld der underdog bin und viele
vierbeiner schönemeier gerne für den
underdog mit und das anders ich spiele
relativ langsam und ich glaube das gibt
einigen anderen casual gamer noch so ein
bisschen hoffnung die altweiber langsam
sind
ich muss ja gar nicht so schnell sein um
gut zu werden und ja ich hab das sei der
hauptgrund
ok dann hoffe ich dass es weiter so
bleibt hofft auch positiven entspannung
hältst und danke dir vielmals das war
sascha die lunge hier im speakers corner
vielen dank über seine arschloch kartei
berichte commander krieger bei uns in
fragen lotto und die auswirkungen der
selben und sehr lustig auch das mit rolf
eden dem playboy aus berlin der immerhin
82 ist und trotzdem sagt sex allzeit
bereit
also viel spaß bei dem oder dem oder dem
oder den von ansonsten bis dann